[Musik]
das könnte noch einmal eine bittere
woche werden leider für uns alle in
deutschland denn es drohen neue corona
einschränkung möglicherweise
ausgangssperren der komplette nah und
fernverkehr könnte weitestgehend
stillgelegt werden es droht noch mehr
home office und noch längere
schulschließung aber was können wir in
deutschland überhaupt noch verkraften
hier in sachen lockdown wie hart muss
und kann dieser lockdown noch werden
darüber spreche ich jetzt gleich unter
anderem mit dem vizekanzler olaf scholz
sie sehen hier bilder wie er vor wenigen
minuten vor gefahren ist hierbei bild
ganz kurz vor dieser so wichtigen
entscheidenden und möglicherweise so
bitteren woche und jetzt live bei uns im
studio der bundesfinanzminister den
vizekanzler schönen guten abend olaf
scholz ein großes thema dieses
wochenendes war ja auch der
cdu-parteitag und die wahl des neuen
vorsitzenden armin laschet wenn sie es
eigentlich schade dass es nicht
friedrich merz geworden ist wissen sie
die frage kenne ich schon
und wie lautet die radfahrer die frage
war als frau kramp karrenbauer cdu
vorsitzende würde ob ich das eigentlich
schade fand dass es nicht herr merz
geworden ist und ja damals gesagt das
ist eine sache der cdu wir arbeiten in
der regierung gut zusammen und im
übrigen wenn es um den wettbewerb die
nächste regierung führt wollen der
sozialdemokrat und sozialdemokraten das
tun die gleiche antwort könnte ich jetzt
wieder geben ich möchte nur eins
ergänzen
herzlichen glückwunsch armin laschet das
haben sie ja schon gearbeitet das haben
sie das schon gesagt aber die frage ist
ja ob man gegen sozialdemokraten antritt
bei der wahl gegen anderen
sozialdemokraten oder ob man
wirtschaftsliberalen und konservativen
gegen sich hat da wäre ja eigentlich der
merzen traumgegner für sie gewesen
auch herr laschet ist mitglied einer
konservativen partei und da geben die
sich nicht so viel übrigen glaube ich
hat die spd auch ein eigenes programm
das sich selber erklärt da braucht man
keine anderen zu haben sie es ab jetzt
mit armin laschet an der spitze mit
einer gestärkten cdu zu tun
ich hoffe dass es eine cdu ist die sich
zueinander findet das ist immer gut fürs
regieren miteinander und wir haben ja
noch große aufgaben zu bewältigen nicht
nur wegen der korona krise aber während
wegen sowieso aber es gibt auch noch ein
paar programmpunkte aus dem
koalitionsvertrag heißt
stärker als bisher mit der neuen führung
mit armin laschet die zusammenarbeit
glaube ich wird sich weiter gut
fortsetzen
ich kann mich da auch nicht beklagen
über die zusammenarbeit mit frau kramp
karrenbauer ich sehe da keinen
unterschied frage ist mit wem sie dann
wirklich zuallererst zusammenarbeiten
also wer ist der erste ansprechpartner
in der cdu ist das ab jetzt ganz klar
armin laschet oder rufen sie eher die
kanzlerin an
ich bin mit der kanzlerin der regierung
zusammen und wir arbeiten im
koalitionsausschuss mit den partei-
position den fraktionsvorsitzenden
zusammen das klappt ganz gut und die
eifersüchteleien den der cdu
untereinander ausgetragen werden mögen
und mit der cdu die will ich nicht
kommentieren da bin ich auch nicht teil
von gehen sie davon aus sie wollen ja
irgendwann wissen wer wenn sie auf dem
plakat sind werden daneben hängt für die
cdu und csu rechnen sie damit dass das
herr laschet am ende sein wird oder
macht es der markus söder aus berufung
gehen sie im moment aus sie kenne ihn ja
auch unheimlich gut will er das keine
ahnung und wir werden sehen ich bin da
ganz gelassen weil wir uns von
vornherein vorgenommen haben einen plan
für die zukunft zu entwickeln für die
20er jahre es geht um respekt es geht
darum wie wir dafür sorgen dass auch in
zehn 20 30 jahren noch gute
arbeitsplätze haben dass wir den
menschengemachten klimawandel aufhalten
können und um ein einiges souverän ist
europa in einer unsicherer werdenden
welt und alles das ist genug um
wahlkampf zu machen wer da gegen mich
antritt das werden wir sehen machen wir
die runde ein bisschen größer und
begrüßen bei uns bei biel zugeschaltet
auch die digital staatsministerin
dorothea die unternehmerinnen und
gründerinnen verena poster hier aus
berlin zugeschaltet und die cdu
spitzenkandidaten aus baden-württemberg
susanne eisenmann ihnen allen schönen
guten abend dorothee bär ich habe olaf
scholz gerade schon gefragt ob sich
nicht für die spitzenkandidatur in der
union ziemlich wurscht es wäre der
cdu-chef wird am ende macht markus söder
würden sie das denn befürworten und
glauben sie dass erst will bisher das ja
nicht gesagt na ja genau so haben sie
jetzt olaf scholz nicht gefragt
ich frage was vielleicht ähnlich aber
nicht genauso ich glaube das
entscheidende ist dass die cdu sich
jetzt entschieden hat wer sie stört das
ist schon mal ganz wichtig weil wir
haben ja unsere parteivorsitzende
ministerpräsidenten schon etwas länger
an der stelle und wie es halt immer
üblich ist die beiden parteivorsitzenden
werden sich jetzt sicher über die frage
unterhalten wer die union auch in die
bundestagswahl führt aber das muss nicht
direkt am tag nach dem cdu parteitag
entschieden werden werden da schon noch
etwas zeit
ja sie haben wir müssen sich die zeit ja
nicht nehmen aber sie wollen sie auch
noch nicht festlegen jetzt für markus
söder frau wer also unsere partei traut
unserem parteivorsitzenden jedes amt der
welt so deswegen sind wir da ganz
entspannt an der stelle
freisen man sie haben sich vor der
cdu-chef wahl klar für friedrich merz
ausgesprochen kostet diese wahl von
armin laschet ihnen jetzt möglicherweise
den erfolg bei der landtagswahl in baden
württemberg schadet ihnen hast nein das
stimmt nicht
es ist richtig mehrheit ich war die
tendenz bei uns gunsten von frieder märz
auf bundes- wirtschaftlichen profils
aber wir haben wie viele einen wollen
parteitage digitalen moderne die cdu als
sich glänzend präsentiert werden drei
starke kandidaten und armin laschet ist
es geworden und jetzt geht es vor allem
darum dass wir beschlossen unsere
inhaltlichen positionen erarbeiten und
dann haben wir auch rückenwind für die
landtagswahl in rheinland pfalz
aber wird sie gerade für die
landtagswahl freisen man nicht helfen
wenn man das stärkste wahlkampf zug
fährt nach vorne spannend und das ist im
moment herr söder
das ist mir schon klar aber es geht
anschließend um die kanzlerkandidatur
das ist schon alles klar war sieht man
so viel es verstanden
ich glaube das ist richtig ist aber er
sagt er ist eben dass sich erstellt und
herr söder die beiden positionen
zusammensetzen das in alle regionen
möglichst das wäre tatsächlich unsere
idee unsere hoffnung unter wenig unter
beteiligung der medien das heißt wenig
querelen wenig steigen und dann zum
geeigneten zeitpunkt entscheiden wer von
beiden für die union die kanzlerschaft
anstrebt das halte ich für den richtigen
weg und markus söder wird sich bei uns
im wahlkampf auch einbringen das ist
wunderbar
der spanische ministerpräsident und das
ist sehr schön
und alles andere wird sich bringen was
wir nicht brauchen können nicht frau
poster sie haben das von außen
beobachten können auch mit großem
interesse vielleicht auch ja ja mit
neugier sowieso aber vielleicht auch an
der hand oder an stellen mit verständnis
soll unverständnis wie finden sie das
wenn da drei männer beim cdu parteitag
antreten die zumindest in umfragen den
beliebtheitswerten alle hinter herrn
scholz liegen und man die nimmt oder
nicht nimmt die davor liegende mich
jetzt sparen im moment zumindest vor dem
parteitag noch und auch markus söder
nicht ganz klar schon sagt er muss es
halt als kanzlerkandidat machen wie
finden sie das
ich glaube bürgerinnen und bürger oder
ich auch ich selber hat eine haben
eigentlich wenig interesse im moment
daran wer welchen posten in zukunft
kriegt wer in der beliebtheitsliste wo
liegt wer gerade aufgestellt wird
sondern ich glaube vielen geht es gerade
so wie kommen jetzt raus aus dieser
pandemie und dieser parteitag der musste
jetzt sein er wurde ja auch noch mal
verschoben das hat es noch mal irgendwie
ein bisschen dramatischer gemacht aber
es wäre irgendwie so schön wenn wir
jetzt mal ein paar monate vielleicht
sogar diese beliebtheitsliste aussetzen
würden und sagen würden wir kümmern uns
wirklich nur um das was jetzt für dieses
land gezählt und es stand nur die drei
zur wahl
herr laschet ist geworden ich glaube wir
sind alle erleichtert dass das thema
abgehakt ist dass uns jetzt wieder
anderen themen zuwenden können ganz
genau das werden wir gleich in der
sendung auch ausführlich tun
ich will noch einen ganz kurz dazuholen
der dieses wochenende auch mit großem
interesse verfolgt hat und das ist der
langjährige thüringische
ministerpräsident langjähriges
cdu-mitglied da war er immer einer der
vorderen bernhard vogel ist uns
zugeschaltet aus speyer ich grüße sie
herzlich herr vogel
was folgte jetzt alle sagen jetzt ja ja
jetzt lass uns wieder um die themen
kümmern und so weiter trotzdem ist das
ja eine nicht ganz unerhebliche
entscheidung die noch bevor steht
nämlich wer jetzt die kanzlerkandidatur
übernimmt frau eisenmann hat gerade
gesagt bloß nicht streiten das einzige
was war was wir verhindern müssen wie
läuft denn das dann jetzt ab zwischen
söder und laschet also wer kommt da
jetzt am besten auf wen zu sie haben so
viel erfahrung viel läuft so was jetzt
also die union hat jahrzehntelange
wie man kanzlerkandidaten gekürt jedes
mal ist das erfolgreich gelungen und es
gibt keinen grund warum das diesmal
nicht gelingen soll
die beiden vorsitzenden der cdu steht
jetzt auch fest müssen sich nach den
wahlen wohl nach ostern zusammen setzen
und müssen die lage erörtern und müssen
eine entscheidung treffen wie jedes mal
vor einer bundestagswahl eine solche
entscheidung getroffen werden musste
und ich habe nicht den geringsten
zweifel dass das auch diesmal gelingt
warum denn nicht wie fanden sie das dass
friedrich merz kurz nach seiner
wahlniederlage angeboten hat man schnell
wirtschaftsminister werden zu wollen
das hat mich ein bisschen überrascht um
ehrlich zu sein denn es geht ja nicht um
das gegenwärtige kabinett merkel sondern
allenfalls um ein neues kabinett nach
den bundestagswahlen und über die
zusammensetzung dieser koalition und
über die berufung der minister sollte
man erst einmal die bundestagswahlen
abwarten und nicht heute schon darüber
spekulieren frau aus da ein bisschen
seltsam kamen das vielen vor
herr merz bietet anschließend nach der
wahlniederlage an naja da könnte man
mich doch zum wirtschaftsminister machen
was fällt ihnen dazu ein
ja es ist ein bisschen so ein typisches
leicht männliches machtgebaren ich habe
gerade einen posten nicht gewonnen dann
greife ich gleich nach dem nächsten oder
fordert ihn ein
was mir da so durch den kopf schoss war
es muss jetzt eigentlich darum gehen die
beste politik zu machen und wenn er
gedanken hat wie man die
wirtschaftspolitik besser machen kann
dann kann er an altmaier anrufen die
sind eine partei die regierung gerade
und das wäre meine hoffnung als bürgerin
dass man nicht erst aktiv wird wenn man
bestimmte aufgabe da hat oder einen
posten sondern dass man auch schon
vorher zusammen arbeitet und deswegen
habe ich das nicht so ganz verstanden
herr scholz es kam der gedanke auf
nachdem friedrich merz eben enttäuscht
war und dann auch gesagt hat naja
als wirtschaftsminister ist jetzt
offenbar auch kein platz mehr für mich
ob für ihn überhaupt noch ein platz in
der cdu ist da kam der gedanke auf mal
vielleicht wäre die fdp auch was einige
fordern dass sogar ganz offensiv ist das
zuzutrauen in die fdp einzutreten
das würde jetzt nachdem er sich gerade
um den cdu vorsitz beworben hat ja nicht
viele schwere inhaltlich getriebene
überzeugungs handlung wirken ja
ehrlicherweise glaube ich sollten wir
uns alle ein bisschen kleiner machen und
nicht den eindruck erwecken wir alleine
wären das die für den erfolg den wir
haben verantwortlich sind da stehen auch
immer viele viele parteimitglieder viele
wählerinnen und wähler dahinter und
denen gegenüber hat man schon die
verpflichtung sich anständig zu benehmen
und sich nicht nur auf sich selbst zu
besinnen
herr vogel viele vor allen dingen der
ost cdu wollten ja friedrich mehr als
als cdu-chef haben ist das eine
niederlage nun auch für eben ganz ganz
viele im osten die sich gewünscht hatten
dass die cdu ja ein bisschen eine andere
richtung rutscht entschuldigen sie bitte
wenn mehrere kandidaten zur wahl stellen
dann wird nach adam riese einer gewinnen
und die anderen kandidaten verlieren und
dass das einen schmerzen markt das gar
nicht aus erfahrungen teilen und das
verstehe ich auch aber daraus kann man
doch keine krisenerscheinungen ableiten
das war doch selbstverständlich gestern
früh dass einer die mehrheit erreichen
würde und zwei sie nicht erreichen
würden
und ich bin sehr dankbar dass norbert
röttgen sich ja auch sofort zur
zusammenarbeit bereit erklärt hat aber
ich habe nicht den geringsten zweifel
dass die wähler von herrn merz genauso
jetzt akzeptiert werden dass herr
laschet vorsitzender geworden ist
selbstverständlich auch in den
ostdeutschen ländern die auf einem
parteitag keine früchte starkes gewicht
haben weil es dort nicht so viele
mitglieder gibt wie im westen
deutschlands selbstverständlich werden
auch die die jetzt getroffene
entscheidung anerkennen das bin ich ganz
sicher und das ist auch das echo dass
ich von den delegierten aus thüringen
beispielsweise
gestern und heute erhalten habe er geht
der blick ganz steil nach vorne auf
diese woche ich habe schon gesagt dass
könnte nochmal eine bittere woche für
uns alle
in deutschland werden weil uns ja
nochmal verschärfte corona maßnahmen
erwarten mit der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
kanzlerin am dienstag wie weit sind wir
herr vogel im moment davon entfernt dass
wir sagen müssen in deutschland
wir schaffen einfach nicht mehr wir
erhalten nicht noch mehr noch härtere
maßnahmen aus also die krone entwicklung
besorgt mich in der tat sehr ich bin
kein fachmann ich kandidaten nicht so
genau beurteilen wie die fachleute die
entscheidungen vorbereiten müssen
aber für mich heißt es man sollte alles
tun um so rasch wie möglich aus der
gegenwärtigen situation herauszukommen
je länger man begrenzte maßnahmen
treffen muss umso schmerzlicher für alle
dann ist es besser eine kurze phase noch
schmerzhafter vorzugehen wenn das dazu
hilft dass wir insgesamt dann auch durch
das impfen beispielsweise aus der
gegenwärtig schwierigen situation
herauskommen
haben sie selbst angst gehen sie vor die
tür
ich bin erfreulicherweise weil ich zu
den hochbetagten oder den alten gehöre
schon gmv ich werde die zweite impfung
in ein paar tagen empfangen und deswegen
bin ich relativ persönlich für mich
wunderbar sorgt aber nicht für die
gesamtsituation in der bundesrepublik
die mir in der tat sorge macht ja in der
tat sie zählen zu der gruppe die eben
als erste geimpft werden durfte haben
sie irgendwelche nebenwirkungen verspürt
oder ist das ganz glatt ganz problemlos
abgelegt die geringste wie sie mir
offensichtlich auch an den und angehören
wunderbar herr scholz wir sprechen jetzt
über die verschärfung das wird eben das
große thema der folgenden woche werden
erleichtert hat sie ganz klar jetzt
gestern nochmal bekannt für
verschärfungen unterstützen sie wies
jetzt müssen weitere maßnahmen ergriffen
werden wir sehen jetzt aktuelle zahlen
die deutlich machen dass die maßnahmen
die wir ergriffen haben sogar wirkung
zeigen die inzidenz werte gehen leicht
zurück in einigen bundesländern mehr in
anderen nur sehr sehr wenig aber das
heißt ja nur dass maßnahmen wirken und
dass das gerücht dass das alles
überflüssig sei falsch ist gleichzeitig
wissen wir dass wir noch nicht so weit
sind wie wir eigentlich gekommen sein
wollten und wir müssen in rechnung
stellen dass die mutation die mit dem
virus jetzt geschieht an mehreren
stellen wenn sie in deutschland ankommen
und in großem maße ankommen auch ganz
dramatische wirkung hinterlassen können
das wird noch mal morgen erörtert mit
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern zusammen aber ich
glaube ist wird der schulter erörtert
das erste mal richtige daten über diese
mutation da weiß man ja nicht viel
drüber wir werden unterschiedliche
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
hören und die daten erörtern
aber um ihre frage zu beantworten ja ich
glaube es wird auch weitere maßnahmen
geben müssen
sie haben gerade mitbekommen dass in
österreich der dortige lockdown ein
wenig verlängert worden ist das werden
wir sicher auch machen gehe davon aus
dass das schon 14 tage sein können die
noch mal dazu kommen und wir werden
sicherlich auch darüber diskutieren
müssen dass man bei dem home offices
nicht bei appellen bleibt wir müssen da
noch einen schritt weiter machen denn im
frühjahr haben viel mehr arbeitgeber
ihren beschäftigten die möglichkeit zu
hause zu arbeiten einen zug geworfen so
dass jegliche und das muss jetzt glaube
ich auch intensiver gemacht lichts im
home-office wollen sie durchsetzen am
dienstag es wird immer darauf ankommen
dass das betrieblich auch geht wir
wollen ja pragmatisch bleiben und nichts
unmögliches verlangen
aber ich glaube dass das schon ein
beitrag sein kann für eine kurze zeit
dazu beizutragen dass die kontakte
reduziert werden übrigens ja dann nicht
nur am arbeitsplatz sondern auch bei dem
weg von und zur arbeit und das hilft ja
können sie beispiele nennen also wäre
ich habe den eindruck immer ganz viele
sind schon im home-office die das
überhaupt können
ganz viele künstler nicht also der
arbeiter bei turniers der arbeit der bei
vw der wird sich schwer tun dass rein
zuhause zu schlachten und das auto
zuhause zu bauen wo ist es im moment
noch möglich das gilt natürlich vor
allem für die büro bereiche dort auch
nicht flächendeckend dabei ein sehr viel
größerem maße als das jetzt der fall ist
zumal ja auch viele unternehmen die
technischen möglichkeiten dazu
geschaffen haben im laufe des letzten
jahres und nach der ersten ausgelegt
dass gewalt und was fällt die noch es
sind vor allem die verwaltung die
dienstleistungsbereiche wo man das
machen kann und ich will noch mal sagen
es geht eigentlich darum dass es richtig
gemacht so wie jeder sich das selber
überlegen würde wenn er darüber
nachdenkt wie kann man dazu beitragen
dass wir das infektionsgeschehen
reduzieren
und jetzt haben wir viele appelle
gemacht uns berichten viele arbeitnehmer
ein arbeitnehmer das sie gern würden
aber dass das nicht so geschätzt wird
und manche haben auch gehört
wenn es nicht vorgeschrieben das mache
ich das nicht ich glaube diesen diesen
appell sollten gehören also wollten wir
ganz viele in deutschland die das
könnten sind noch nicht im home office
das heißt auch sie würden dafür
plädieren die zu zwingen mit einer home
office pflicht sind sie dafür
unterstützen sie das als ich unterstütze
er stark dass überall da wo es möglich
ist auch von homburgs gebraucht wird er
gebrauch gemacht wird weil es natürlich
entscheidend ist dass die
infektionszahlen runtergehen auf dem weg
zur arbeit vom weg zur arbeit und alle
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber möchten
natürlich auch gesunde mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter also ich versteh
manchmal ein bisschen die diskussion
nicht weil es oft so rüberkommt so die
bösen arbeitgeberinnen arbeitgeber
machen nicht alles möglich aber jemand
der sich natürlich damit corona
infiziert kolleginnen und kollegen an
steckt da haben natürlich die
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber
wesentlich weniger davon also in so
stand ist eine hohe bereitschaft da
definitiv da wir müssen es aber so
pragmatisch ausgestalten dass es auch
jetzt nicht wieder dazu kommt dass alles
kontrolliert werden muss und dass wir
mehr damit beschäftigt sind zu schauen
ob regelungen eingehalten werden sondern
ganz wichtig ist dass nochmals stärker
kontakte reduziert werden wir sind in
einer sehr herausfordernden angespannten
situation aber ich sage auch ganz offen
ich weiß dass auch viele maßnahmen jetzt
teilweise an die grenze der belastung
gehen für chile
auf der anderen seite bekomme ich auch
täglich so viele zuschriften bürgerinnen
und wirklich ganz ganz dringend auch
mahnen dass wir noch mehr tun
also ich glaube dass die bereitschaft
auch noch mal für einige wochen
vielleicht sogar einige wenige monate
noch mal einschränkungen in kauf zu
nehmen viel viel größer ist als man
manchmal so als ich fühlte
veröffentlichte meinung glaubt home
office pflicht frau pause was halten sie
davon
also bei denen bei denen es geht weil
die infrastruktur da ist oder weil sie
wie gesagt im dienstleistungsbereich
arbeiten bei denen sofort bei allen
anderen sachen jetzt betriebe schließen
oder jetzt gucken was können wir noch zu
machen da ist ein bisschen meine frage
wie sozusagen schöpfen ja die maßnahmen
noch nicht aus die wir haben also ffb
zwei masken im öffentlichen nahverkehr
in den supermärkten in der bahn im
flugzeug schnelltests da wo wir
menschenleben schützen können also
gerade in dem pflegeheim bei den älteren
warum machen wir da nicht mehr erst noch
unsere hausaufgaben bevor wir jetzt
sozusagen so um uns schauen und sagen
was könnten jetzt mal noch zu machen
denn in vielen betrieben ich habe selber
komme selber aus einem mittelständischen
unternehmen
der betrieb lief das ganze jahr 2020 da
gab es keinen einzigen corona fall die
die ein der einzelhandel hat ganz viel
maßnahmen getroffen in der korona zeit
also diese alle über einen kamm scheren
taktik die es aus meiner sicht keine
strategie sondern inzwischen eher ein
armutszeugnis also das ist ja fast ein
appell an sie herr scholz bitte keine
betriebe schließen es reicht jetzt bitte
nicht noch weiter gehen und die leute
dazu zu zwingen ins home office zu gehen
sagt frau poster in den letzten halbsatz
habe ich nicht gehört aber keine
betriebe schließen das ist völlig
richtig
das hat auch niemand vor dass wir jetzt
die wirtschaft lahmlegen haben wir
übrigens in dem ersten lockdown im
frühjahr des letzten jahres auch nicht
gemacht das ist ausgeschlossen
sie werden die produktion wird nicht
jetzt stillstehen weil sie sagen ich wir
müssen noch mehr leuten dagegen dass wir
eine solche entscheidung treffen und ich
will auch ausdrücklich sagen wir haben
auch allen anlass alles dafür zu tun
dass die wirtschaftszweige die jetzt von
schließungen betroffen sind die damit zu
kämpfen haben und wo ja viele
damit kämpfen dass ihr lebenswerk
erhalten bleibt die arbeitsplätze
unternehmen die ihre mieten zahlen
müssen die mit großen herausforderung
konfrontiert sind
dass wir die unterstützen ich bin
jedenfalls wild entschlossen zusammen
mit meinem kollegen altmaier dafür sorge
zu tragen dass wir diese
wirtschaftshilfen die wir für die zeit
in diesem jahr konzipiert haben nochmal
grosszügiger ausgestaltet nochmal
großzügiger und dass die dann da kommen
wir später noch mal zu vielleicht auch
ankommen bei den betroffenen ja auf alle
fälle großzügiger ich finde das ja die
zahl der die größenordnung der
unternehmen noch mal nach oben anpassen
müssen dass also auch ein betrag nicht
so wie er durchs raster falls zu
anderthalb millionen euro als monatliche
leistung da ein blick genommen werden
kann
ich glaube dass wir etwas tun müssen für
einzelhändler die saison ware haben ab
märz wollen sie schon die neue verkaufen
so etwas wie eine praktische lösung die
betrug nicht betrugsanfällig ist da
haben wir uns sehr weit vorangebracht zu
entwickeln das wird jetzt glaube ich
auch schnell was werden damit alle
darauf kalkulieren können den die alte
ware ist ja noch nicht bezahlt weil noch
nichts verdient wurde dann kommt schon
die neue das ist schon eine ziemliche
herausforderung ich habe mit vielen
einzelhändlern gesprochen habe mir das
auch mal konkret angeguckt und ich kann
nur sagen dann werden wir was machen wir
sagt also das nächste mega paket das
gehört ja einfach dazu dass wir das
sowieso vorbereitete große paket dass
die überbrückungshilfe in zossen
betrifft noch ausbauen und zwar genau da
wo wir jetzt zielgerichtet mitbekommen
haben dass es nötig ist auch das muss
man ja ganz klar sagen weil die
schließungen jetzt ja länger dauern als
die letztes jahr gedacht waren
das wird richtig teuer also jetzt dann
für die die noch arbeiten aktuell noch
steuern zahlen freisen man wir waren
auch schon an dem punkt ist das
überhaupt notwendig herr scholz hat
schon gesagt die zahlen sind so ganz
leicht etwas besser geworden in den
letzten tagen wir schauen einmal auf
unsere morgige bild seite 2 und dort
haben wir diese drei kurven einmal
gezeigt und die frage gestellt ob
wirklich eine verschärfung des lok downs
im moment notwendig ist also trotz
dieser kurven eine kurve nämlich die
mittlere zeigt unter anderem die der
infektionszahlen aktuell außerdem die
belegung der intensivbetten dort das
heißt das ist jetzt keine totale
entwarnung aber wie sie sehen zumindest
eine ganz ganz leichten rückgang in aldi
drei kurven ist das der punkt frau
eisenmann wo man gut erklären kann das
jetzt trotzdem der verschärfung
notwendig ist ein zunächst ich glaube
ich dass es richtig ist dass wir
momentan in einem scharfen lockdown sind
ich halte es auch für richtig darüber
nachzudenken dass man die maßnahmen
jetzt sicher nochmal beim balinger
grundlage ist aber für mich schon
wir brauchen wir verlässliche zahlen in
ihre grafiken haben ja eben gezeigt das
ist durchaus eine entwicklung geht man
muss den maßnahmen ja auch die chance
geben zu wirken
und ich habe manchmal den eindruck dass
wir auch mit den zahlen und zwar ein
bisschen schwer tun
wir reden immer noch zahlen hinterher
ist immer noch nicht mehr so viel
getestet wie vor weihnachten das sind
alles relativierungen gehen in
bürgerinnen und bürgern schwierig zu
vermitteln sind wir frauen merken wir
brauchen deutlich mehr fest wir müssen
wissen wer infiziert ist und diese in
quarantäne nehmen zu können aber die
maßnahmen die wir aufsetzen müssen ihre
wirkung auch erst in fahrt entfalten
können deshalb weil ich so schwierig
jetzt auch da auf uns zu sprechen schon
die zusage gab es aber noch mal ganz
klar frau eisenmann dann würden sie im
moment dann nicht verschärfen sondern
erstmal abwarten mit den beschlossenen
maßnahmen weitermachen also die frage
ist so wie ich tatsächlich wie kann man
weiter wo beiden wir man weiter
verschärfen mehr home office dateien
aber es ist aus meiner sicht durchaus ja
auch notwendig die maßnahmen würden zu
lassen in baden württemberg hat die
verschärfung des lokals überhaupt ihres
geht es diese woche also die vergangene
woche wirkung entfaltet also so gesehen
glaube ich dass es richtig ist musst du
gehen aber nicht zu langfristig zu
planen und wie gesagt was ist immer
wirtschaft angeht da muss ich schon
sagen da ist natürlich wirklich viel ist
inzwischen auch keinen die kinder und er
stolz wenn ich höre schneller flexibler
ja es wird schon seit november
und versprochen angekommen ist da
zumindest in baden württemberg sieht die
klagen gross bisher abschlagszahlungen
ansonsten noch gar nicht was ich mir
gleich noch mal versprochen da sprechen
wir gleich noch mal noch mal tiefer
darüber was von dem was von dem geld an
es war ein mann ich will einmal bei
diesen punkt bleiben ist das wirklich
der richtige zeitpunkt und lässt es sich
den den menschen in deutschland wirklich
verkaufen jetzt noch mal die
daumenschrauben anzuziehen
wir schauen einmal was der virologe
klaus stöhr uns heute gesagt hat und man
darf eigentlich auch nicht vergessen
dass die saison
die pandemie saison jetzt für dieses
virus nicht nach dem nächsten blog da
und aufhört sondern gehört im april auf
wenn der winter vorbei ist und es wäre
falsch zu glauben dass man mit einer
jetzigen scharfen verstärkt verschärfung
der maßnahmen durch den ganzen winter
kommen aber man muss ein langfristiges
konzept haben das man elastisch an die
entsprechende infektion situation
anpassen kann
und das sehe ich leider noch nicht da
ich sehe nur den nächsten block dauern
bis die nächsten drei vier wochen und
ich dann weitergehen soll er sagen alles
wissen wir nicht was er sagte auch jetzt
schon das wird bis ostern so seien also
das ziel im winter die zahlen unter 50
zu kriegen das können sie im grunde
vergessen das wird nicht funktionieren
im winter deswegen werden wir auf jeden
fall sie sagen die nächsten zwei wochen
er sagt bis mindestens ostern lockt dann
haben wir müssen die zahlen runter
kriegen und ich glaube die tatsache dass
wir ein paar gute ergebnisse sehen die
sie ja auch morgen in ihrer zeitung
veröffentlichen werden zeigt ja dass das
auch gelingt und das wird auch weiter
gelingen und wenn wir jetzt sehr präzise
fast logisch weiteren maßnahmen
ergreifen
dann hilft das auch wo ich einen recht
gäbe ist dass es nicht richtig wäre
jetzt in sonne fast unbegründete
rhetorik zu verfallen wo man sagt jetzt
muss noch was drauf jetzt muss noch was
auf das muss schon begründet sein und
ein wichtiger grund warum wir jetzt
zusätzliche präzise maßnahmen zu den
bereits ergriffenen auf den weg bringen
sollten aus meiner sicht ist dass wir
nicht abwarten können bis wir in drei
monaten alle wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse über die mutationen haben
sondern wenn wir dann herausfinden wir
hätten man jetzt in diesen tagen was
entschieden und uns ärgern in drei
monaten das ist nicht gemacht hatten
dann wäre das ein fehler also müssen wir
jetzt diese präzisen maßnahmen machen
aber das geht schon darum dass wir
runter kommen damit wir dann auch wer
sich also er sagt ja das ziel ist
unrealistisch weil sie schaffen sie im
winter nie egal was sie machen auf die
auf die 50 wollen sie
darunter dass wir in diese richtung
marschieren das muss weiter gelten
und das wird uns dann auch die luft
verschaffen die wir brauchen um
lockerungsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen und es
wird uns auch die luft verschaffen damit
wir mit der potenziellen gefahr des
neuen virus vielleicht so umgehen können
dass es sich bei uns nicht so auswirken
wie anderswo wir haben ja gesehen dass
die kurz nachdem das passiert ist in
anderen ländern ergriffenen maßnahmen
sogar dazu geführt haben dass das wieder
nach unten wie lange wird das bei uns
dauern bis wir ein ziel erreicht haben
wo wir dann mal irgendwann das
lichtermeer meine zielsetzung ist schon
so dass wir so sorgfältig jetzt morgen
und übermorgen diskutieren dass wir
maßnahmen ergreifen von denen wir
annehmen dürfen dass sie uns in die nähe
unserer zielsetzung bringen so dass wir
dann auch nicht die ganze zeit immer nur
weiter machen müssen ja ja ist schon sie
sollen also sie sagen jetzt die
maßnahmen das wird sozusagen der letzte
schuss sein sagt jetzt mit meinen worten
noch härter wird es dann nicht aber das
muss wirken aber wie schnell haben sie
wird es einen zeitplan dafür geben oder
haben sie was im kopf
es rechnet uns ja ständig leute der zu
den beruf haben vor wie schnell unsere
maßnahmen wirken
wir wurden darüber belehrt über die zeit
hinweg dass es rauf und runter geht auch
durchaus mit großen steigerungsraten im
die gute wie schlechte richtung und
deshalb kann man schon annehmen dass die
ergriffenen maßnahmen und die
hoffentlich dann zusätzlich vereinbarten
präzisen genau überlegten maßnahmen
zusammen dazu beitragen dass wir eine
bessere situation kommen denn das wir
aber präzise präzise nicht was den
zeitraum angeht also sagen jetzt nicht
bis ende märz oder erst nach ostern oder
wir wollen dass alle zwei wochen will
das hielte ich für sehr unseriös
aber ich finde wir sollten die maßnahmen
so machen dass wir die hoffnung haben
dass sie auch in dem dann geplanten
zeitraum größere wirkung zeigt
das ist service ja also wir wissen es
noch nicht wie wann wann es
möglicherweise licht am ende des tunnels
gebe ich sagen und kommen das kommt
übrigens ja auch dadurch dass wir früher
oder später ja dann doch viele
bürgerinnen und bürger geimpft haben
werden und deshalb schon jetzt immerhin
verstehen können dass diese jeden von
uns alle die ich kenne
unglaublich belastende situation mal
vorbei ist ja finanzieren und bürger
wenn mir das gefühl das wollen wir auch
mal zu ende so ganz ganz kurz strich zu
untersagen immer präzise frau bär lassen
sie uns ganz ganz präzise dann über
diese maßnahmen sprechen werden ihrer
ansicht nach bundesweite ausgangssperren
so eine präzise regelung die jetzt
kommen müsste ja ja wir haben es ja
momentan auch in bayern und da
funktioniert sie auch sehr gut muss man
sagen es wird auch akzeptiert weil es
auch ganz klar der regelungen sind und
man sieht es ja auch sehr mehr selber
bericht erstattet über eine hochzeit die
aus den fugen geraten ist mit über 60
teilnehmern die sich an gar keine regeln
gehalten haben
und da hilft natürlich so eine
ausgangssperre und da hilft natürlich
auch wenn man bundesweit einheitliche
regelung hat weil die für alle ganz klar
ist und ganz leicht nachzuvollziehen
werde er stolz ganz präzise antwort
präzise ausgangssperren wer das was was
die zahlen präzise runter bringen würde
ich finde das ist eine mögliche maßnahme
aber nicht die idee als allererste
ansteht zumal sich die inzidenz wirke in
einigen ländern ja ganz anders
entwickeln als anderswo
deshalb finde ich sollten wir erstmal
uns auf diesen maßnahmen konzentrieren
die jetzt wirklich schnell was bringen
und über die zuerst diskutieren alles
andere wird sich ja auch debattiert
werden
und das ist aus meiner sicht wie wir
über das home office und über eine
zeitlich absehbare verlängerung das
hinbekommen doch die inzidenz werte auf
das niveau zu drücken dass wir an
vorhaben also seine ausgangssperren sind
sie nicht dafür noch mal drauf zu
satteln
ich finde man darf überhaupt zu nicht
sagen dass man das nicht diskutieren
sollte aber aber das was er mir
zuallererst ein feld sind jetzt erstmal
andere maßen und die zuerst diskutiert
werden muss noch mal die frage an herrn
vogel wir sprechen jetzt auch über
ausgangssperren aber eben auch über home
office pflicht über viele andere dinge
ich hatte schon versucht herauszufinden
was es den menschen noch zuzumuten wie
ist ihr eindruck im moment in speyer bei
ihnen in der heimat in den gesprächen
die sie führen auch aus der familie aus
dem freundeskreis können wir überhaupt
noch härtere maßnahmen verkraften
also der allgemeine durchgehende wunsch
ist dass wir diese situation so rasch
wie möglich überwinden
und es versteht ja eine große
bereitschaft wenn es entsprechend
erklärt wird weitere maßnahmen notfalls
in kauf zu nehmen und dabei bin ich
dafür dass wir einheitliche maßstäbe für
die ganze bundesrepublik setzen dass wir
aber zulassen dass in den einzelnen
städten und kreisen maßnahmen erst
ergriffen werden wenn die insolvenz
besonders hoch ist und nicht überall
gleichmäßig warum soll man in bremen
einführen was in thüringen notwendig ist
nein man muss es abbrechen auf die
einheit der kreis und auf die einheit
der städte und aus diesem grund sind die
grafiken die sie vorhin gezeigt haben
ermutigend aber nicht ermutigend locker
zu lassen sondern ermutigend verstärkt
fortzufahren damit wir endgültig
dauerhaft bessere lösung und begruben
frau poster vielen dank erstmal herrn
vogel für diese worte aus speyer danke
ihnen ganz herzlich frau poster zu
befürchten steht dass wir die schulen
noch länger geschlossen halten müssen
wie sie eindruck auch aus der eigenen
erfahrung geht das noch schaffen wir das
noch also ich glaube so der
realitätscheck in den familien ist ja
mutter oder vater meistens mutter sitzen
mit dem kind vor der schul cloud die
funktioniert fast in keinem bundesland
problemlos dann hat man in aufgabenblatt
was angezeigt wird dann muss man das
wahrscheinlich ausdrucken ausfüllen
wieder einscannen hochladen
dann hat man vielleicht noch mehr als
ein kind und wenn man sich das jetzt
alles noch vorstellt mit ich hab gar
kein gerät oder ich hab keinen drucker
oder mein kind hat lernschwierigkeiten
oder ich bin in einer sozial schwierigen
situation dann sind einfach familien
eltern und kinder an der
belastungsgrenze und insofern als ich
ebenso zu hörte dachte ich so
ausgangssperren wo sollen wir denn hin
ja also wir können kein restaurant kein
war kein klub klar ist dass wieder eine
weitere einschränkung der freiheit aber
wohl wirklich die familie nächten und
zwar millionen ja das sind ja richtig
viele
das ist tagsüber die kinder haben kein
sportunterricht mehr weder in der schule
natürlich noch nachmittags jetzt ist
auch für die unter zwölfjährigen
jeglicher sport im freien gestrichen
worden dh die kinder bewegen sich
weniger zu hause gehen sich alle auf den
keks also das sind einfach soziale
spannungen und natürlich wenn die jetzt
noch über wochen gehen dann ist das eine
situation wo ganz viel in die knie gehen
werden und insofern auch da mich sagen
die schulen bleiben zu oder offen
sondern die kinder zuerst wieder in die
schule gehen zu lassen die zu hause
besonders leiden und da ein
wechselmodell zu schaffen dass die
bevorzugt werden wäre eine maßnahme ffb
zwei masten für lehrer und lehrerinnen
also da sind viele dinge die wir tun
können
ich glaube auch da darf es nicht immer
nur diese pauschalen antworten geben
alle sitzen zu hause oder alle sitzen in
der schule
wir haben ja eine kultusministerin in
der runde die cdu spitzenkandidat in
baden württemberg frau reisen macht
können sie da ein bisschen zumindest für
baden württemberg ein bisschen hoffnung
machen dass die schulen wieder öffnen
können oder werden wir diese woche das
gegenteil erleben und noch eine längere
schulpause also zumindest von echtem
unterwegs präsenzunterricht also ich
kann nur sagen wir werden uns da teile
ich die einschätzung von brockhaus noch
differenziert vorgehensweise zu trauen
müssen
es kann nicht sein dass kitas und
grundschulen jetzt noch über wochen oder
monate einfach geschlossen sind
ich bin davon differenziertes vorgehen
bei älteren schülerinnen und schüler
werden ist dann unterricht das ist
sicher gut funktioniert übrigens in
baden württemberg am ersten tag
schwierigkeiten gehabt aber seitdem sehr
sehr gut nur klar ist gerade kleinen
kindern könne nicht digital lernen die
können ja zum teil und über lesen und
schreiben auch digitales betreuung ist
schwierig und deshalb muss man
differenzieren und ich kann nur sagen
wir müssen uns dringend überlegen kitas
und grundschulen zu öffnen weil wir
kinder haben die auch aus schwierigen
sozialen verhältnissen kommen psychisch
belastet sind es darf nicht sein dass
immer gerade kleine kinder die verlierer
dieser pandemie werden und viele eltern
können auch nicht viele eltern haben
auch keine komfortablen wohnsituation
und deshalb werden wir uns dringend
überlegen müssen
so wie dass es am dienstag auch mit
berücksichtigt bei allem bekenntnis zum
lockdown und dafür dass wir momentan
haben noch geduld haben müssen unsere
maßnahmen auch durchaus nachhaltig und
hat sein wissen aber bei kindern bei
kleinkindern muss es perspektive eben
unter da müssen wir differenziert
vorgehen alles über einen kamm zu
scheren
baumärkte du bei aller wertschätzung von
baumärkten merktest du so eine linie ist
passt ist du einfach und wird gerade die
bedürfnisse von kindern nicht gerecht
gerade von kleinen innen frau brooke und
frau bär der druck von ganz ganz vielen
familien die schulen wieder zu eröffnen
der ist ja auch so groß weil die in der
praxis merken das funktioniert mit der
digitalisierung noch nicht an ihrer
schule
der druck ist deswegen so groß weil sie
eben befürchten dass ganz ganz lange die
bildung verloren geht die eigentlich in
diesen wochen in diesen monaten erfolgen
müsste was sagen sie als digital
staatsministerin den familien die genau
das sagen wir können das überhaupt nicht
ausgleichen aufgrund der ja nicht
vorhandenen digitalisierung an den
schulen was wir im moment an bildung
verlieren durch corona denen sage ich
dass ich sie ganz gut nachvollziehen
können jeden einzelnen tag wir haben
selber drei schulpflichtige kinder
also spreche ich nicht nur theoretisch
als politikerin sondern auch ganz
praktisch als mutter mit drei kindern in
unterschiedlichen schulstufen mit
ungefähr 1000 verschiedenen anwendungen
und unterschiedlichen servern und clouds
und systemen als unser frank weiß ich
ganz genau was das für große
herausforderungen sind
und ich sage es auch ganz offen ich habe
seit beginn meiner amtszeit mehrere
schulgipfel auch im kanzleramt
veranstaltet und es war wahnsinnig
schwer auch im ersten jahr 2018
auch die kultusministerkonferenz dazu zu
bewegen sich mit uns als
bundespolitikerin dann auch an einen
tisch zu setzen
warum weil es natürlich immer hieß dass
es alles ländersache der bund soll sich
nicht einmischen mit dortmund aber schon
alt wir durften uns als unter frauen
einmischen mit den 6,5 milliarden
aber wenn es dann soweit schalter und
sollte an den zuständigkeiten aber an
den zuständigkeiten aber dass
spannender weise letztes jahr auch etwas
einfacher dann plötzlich da hat die
zusage der kmk keine zwölf monate
gedauert sondern war dann innerhalb von
zwölf minuten da weil man schon gemerkt
hat vielleicht müssen wir diese ganzen
befindlichkeiten auch hinten angestellt
sein aber wir reden dann nach so vielen
monaten immer noch über befindlichkeiten
frau wer das trifft ja nicht exklusiv
sie aber sie können ja jetzt alle in der
runde hier frau bär r scholz auch
kultusministerin eisenmann sagen so ab
jetzt ist es absolute priorität wir
haben schon viel zu viele monate an den
schulen verpennt wenn es jetzt immer
noch lehrer gibt die ihre
digitalisierung so aussehen lassen dass
sie einmal die woche eine mail schicken
mit den saiten angaben die ihre schüler
zu lesen haben dann ist es einfach
peinlich übernehmen sie die
verantwortung hier in dieser runde wer
wer will das machen frau bär herr scholz
vorweisen man die können wir diesen
tagen ihre zuständigkeit habe nämlich
auch verantworten
aber sie sitzen im chrysler und also
wenn es ja deswegen sagt ich möchte
jetzt nochmal mit ist es auch nicht so
einfach sondern man muss doch mal ganz
klar sagen die forscher erfahrungen
haben wir alle gemacht man muss doch mal
ganz deutlich sagen wenn wir uns doch
jahrelang auch an unseren kindern
versündigt das digitale bildung an der
schule mit allen ausreden immer nicht
möglich war weil das war immer auch gift
das digitales in die schulen
hereinkommen sollen
und erst durch corona würde wohl wurde
wirklich mal der vorhang gelüftet
um mal zu zeigen wo es funktioniert und
wo es eben nicht funktioniert an welcher
stelle und ich bin froh dass auch durch
corona ganz großer druck auf dieses
thema gekommen ist dass wir jetzt auch
angefangen haben mit einigen
bundesländern dass sie sich auch der
haken die schul klar wird angeschlossen
haben dass wir jetzt mal die gleiche
basis schaffen können was ihnen die
mindestanforderungen weil es eben nichts
davon ausgeben sollen dass es eine
benachteiligung ist in welchem
bundesland ich lebe an welcher schule
ich bin und werde ich gesagt wurde ob
ich eine motivierte lehrerinnen oder
eine nicht motivieren ihr habt ihr
beweise man stehen sie da immer im weg
mit ihren blöden befindlichkeiten in den
ländern wäre wenn man den bund gehört
selbstverständlich weil wenn der bund
was macht ein punkt turniers zügig
umgesetzt technisch auf höchstem niveau
ich glaube das übrigens
die bürger sind wie wenig verständnis
für solche schuldzuweisungen genau genau
bildungsbereich im bildungsbereich im
digitalbereich da nachholbedarf
unterstellen dass man darüber ins spiel
gemacht aber allein in baden württemberg
in den letzten monaten 300.000 das ist
thema glasfaserausbau in ganz
deutschland vielleicht sollte man sich
die förderkriterien des bundes da auch
noch mal anschauen
alles themen wo man gemeinsam etwas
erreichen dann haben wir nachholbedarf
damit den schulen ist das bewusstsein
angekommen
wenn ich mir zum teil aber anschauen wie
gesundheitsämter noch arbeiten mit fax
und bleistift übrigens auch in bayern
da muss ich sagen frage ich mich schon
wie digitales müssen wir sagen wir haben
in ganz deutschland nachholbedarf wie
siehst du billig immer nur zu sagen was
die kultusminister und die länder alles
verschlafen haben
ich bin da hat nur schaftlich unterwegs
wir müssen was tun nur übrigens bei
kleinen kindern bei vielen in der ersten
zweiten dritten vierten klasse als
weniger mit gerade ausstattung nun oder
sie können nicht digital arbeiten bei
denen nicht mal lesen und schreiben
können
auch das gehört zur wahrheit und du
deshalb ihre herzliche bitte lassen uns
um die besten lösungen ringen wir müssen
was tun aber gegenseitige
schuldzuweisungen und logischen aus
berlin helfen uns nicht weiter
mehrere bilder haben sie trotzdem beide
jetzt ganz nebenbei gemacht genau die
schuldzuweisungen herr scholz sie können
doch jetzt sagen zumindest die
bundesregierung wir machen das jetzt
einfach ich kenne die
länderzuständigkeit auch aber worauf
warten sie wenn ich auf eine solche
krise einfach das jetzt durchzusetzen
und so lange vor ort hin zu gucken bis
die unterschriften überall darunter sind
und bis die lehrer jede woche
fortschritts pläne hinlegen dass das
besser läuft also wenn ich das alles
richtig beobachtet haben hat der bund
haben die länder haben die
kultusministerin und kultusminister
haben ganz viele sehr aktive tolle
lehrerinnen lehrer in den schulen viele
aktive und engagierte schulleiterinnen
und schulleiter längst gesagt wir machen
das und diesen schulterschluss sollten
wir jetzt auch zustande bringen und
dafür sorgen dass es sich tatsächlich
ändert ich hoffe dass diese schlimme
krise die wir mit der korona pandemie
haben in dieser hinsicht auch noch mal
ein ganz großer booster ist dafür sorgt
dass wir viel
mehr solcher möglichkeiten haben und sie
auch nutzen nicht nur in der schule aber
eben auch in der schule
und wenn wir uns jetzt unterhaken dann
kriegen wir das auch hin ich jedenfalls
finde das ist eine top priorität für die
deutsche politik
ich möchte sie einmal in die runde dazu
holen der herr scholz kennt sie noch aus
der spd in baden-württemberg wird sie
frau eisenmann vermutlich auch kennen
wir sprechen hier gerade über engagement
an den schulen und wer es richten möchte
müsste schieben uns hin und her die
zuständigkeiten und die schuld in so
einer krise wer kann's anpacken wer kann
es richten woran hapert es ihrer meinung
nach und warum sind die ganzen laptops
von der frau eisenmann noch nicht
angekommen und von herrn scholz das
ganze gilt nicht wenn wir so eine große
krise haben gesprochen jetzt sage dir
jeder spritze jugendliche interessieren
dass nicht die klitschkos
die jetzt gültige sie wollen da geht
nicht sagen die wollen eine ehrliche
abschlussprüfung haben die
digitalisierung in deutschland deshalb
bin ich ja auch aus der wirtschaft raus
in die politik hinein gegangen weil ich
gesagt habe wir haben fast alles
verschlafen und sind vielleicht noch
exportweltmeister noch dieses jahr aber
dann ist vorbei warum beide nicht
erkrankt haben was die zukunft braucht
wir haben viel zu viel
gelabert wir brauchen ergebnisse kinder
müssen in die schule in den schulen ein
um hier sind die werden es nicht
schaffen durch unsere mangelhafte welt
digitalisierung zu haben ich habe selber
eine lern stück von ja über 300
jugendliche
wir sind ständig am telefonieren mit den
zahlen zufrieden ich hab ihm
nachfolgende jugendliche thema raus aus
der engeren und sie wollen raus sie
wollen was lernt sie öffentlich tief
werden durch die diskussion eine gesamte
generation in eine schieflage bringen
und da sag ich ganz einfach hört auf zu
schwätze macht was macht was über machen
machen nicht zurückschauen alles andere
frau poster trifft das zu dritte welt
digitalisierung ja also das kann man
sicherlich bemängeln wie unser
bildungssystem da steht nur bringt uns
das ja aktuell nichts ich könnte jetzt
auch sagen dass ich seit vier jahren in
jeder talkshow in jeder zeitung die zehn
dinge fordere die man jetzt tun muss wie
dorothee bär eben gesagt haben gab es
schuhe gipfel und schulgipfel wo man
überlegt hat was zu tun ist aber wenn
uns jetzt hier jemand zuhört der gerade
morgen früh wieder mit seinen 7 11 13
jährigen vorm rechner sitzt dann sagte
er das ist ja schön dass ihr das
irgendwie alles wissen und alles
gefordert habe aber es ist ja nicht
passiert was machen wir denn jetzt und
so würde ich jetzt daran gehen und sagen
wie können wir jetzt aktuell im lockdown
der schulen es leichter machen für die
eltern und zum einen wäre das zu sagen
es gibt in diesem schuljahr keine noten
und keine klassenarbeiten mehr
das sind einfach druck vom system also
außer für die abschlussjahrgänge weil
die eltern sind so die lehrer und
lehrerinnen sind so die schulleiter
geben alles alle sind kurz vor dem
burn-out und wenn wir jetzt noch
klassenarbeiten und noten verteilen wer
soll denn was das jahr ist das klären
wir direkt in der runde er schon als
wären sie dafür ganz kurz bekommen
gleich zurück zu ihnen frau aus da wäre
das was sie vernünftig finden dieses
jahr schulnoten aussetzen keine
zeugnisse
ich glaube dass wir die abschlussklassen
retten müssen und die guten ein abitur
möglich machen müssen aber auch die
anderen abschlüsse und ob man jetzt
deshalb tests aussetzen muss das weiß
ich nicht man muss aber die lage
berücksichtigen und wenn ich das richtig
verstanden hat tun dass auch alle da
soll kein schüler kann die schülerin war
einseitig den lehrern halt wieder nein
das müssen sie das muss schon gemeinsam
besprochen werden das werden alle länder
jeweils konkret regeln da wird auch viel
diskutiert das kann man ganz konkret
auch nachvollziehen
und ich will nur dazu sagen es geht
darum dass man eine lösung macht die
funktioniert für die schülerinnen und
schüler und für die eltern und ich kann
nur unterstützen was eben da gesagt
wurde
viele haben das gefühl ich kann nicht
mehr und deshalb müssen wir darauf auch
reagieren und sehr vorsichtig seien nur
sehr knapp aus da sagt eine lösung wäre
jetzt keine tests mehr machen keine
prüfung und die belohnung aus
den ansatz von braut pragmatisch
anzugehen ziemlich gut ich finde diesen
in einen konkreten vorschlag nicht so
ganz überzeugend aber ich weiß dass alle
gucken wie kriegt man das hin mit dem
abitur auch mit der tatsache dass
bestimmte sachen nicht stattgefunden
haben und wenn jetzt darüber nachgedacht
wird wie kann man möglichst flexibel wo
das geht mit wechsel unterricht
bestimmte unterrichts sachen verkaufen
lassen dann geht es ja auch darum auf
die realität der familien rücksicht zu
nehmen und das gleiche haben wir gemacht
da für mich sehr sehr sehr gekämpft dass
wir jetzt mit der erweiterung der
möglichkeiten über das krankengeld eine
möglichkeit geschaffen haben wie
elterngeld mehr kinder können völlig
klar verizon man noch mal ganz kurz an
sie gespiegelt der vorschlag von frau
poster also benotung jetzt einmal
aussetzen keine prüfung mehr werden sie
dabei nein da ist mir schlichtweg zu
undifferenziertes da geht es gleich
dieses pauschale sei nicht wichtig wir
müssen differenziert vorgehen und das
heißt pädagogisch angemessen weniger
arbeiten arbeiten gezielt einsetzen
übrigens viele schülerinnen und schüler
wollen nicht schuljahr haben wo ihn
nachher ewig nachgesagt wird naja ihr
hattet es besonders einfach ist
berufungen prüfungsvorbereitungen ja
auch wenn sich 22 stattfinden und
deshalb pädagogisch angemessen wo es
spielräume gibt da wirklich bayer scholz
soll man sie nutzen
aber nicht pauschal auch nicht auszahlen
alle ferien verlängern oder alle ferien
absagen oder gar schon mit anhängen es
ist viel zu pauschal gilt so einfach
gedacht die realität ist differenzierter
das müssen wir besser spiegeln und
deshalb ja es muss fair sein
faktisch seien aber nicht pauschal alles
absagen was übrigens für schülerinnen
und schüler durchaus auch wichtig ist
übrigens auch wichtig um zu überprüfen
wie der leistungsstand ist und wo kann
man ihnen helfen in der welt herum weil
man festgestellt hat dass sie aufgrund
dieser situation zu wenig
die frage ist ob die lehrer das aktuell
überhaupt beurteilen können aus der
ferne frau wie ist ihr eindruck
komm ich kommen sofort zurück wo er frau
aus der frau wie war ihr eindruck
gewehrt es nicht zumindest wäre das
nicht zumindest moralisch völlig in
ordnung diesem jahr auch kein
sitzenbleiben zuzulassen
das wollte ich gerade ansprechen ich
glaube eine möglichkeit ist tatsächlich
zu sagen es muss niemand dieses
schuljahr wiederholen aufgrund des
evangelischen situation aber ich mag
jetzt schon dass die stadt braucht
geachtet wird nie wenn noten gemacht
welche werden gemacht welche leistungen
zählen tatsächlich habe jetzt auch
feststellen können dass es auch sich in
den lehrplänen oder in den wochen
aufgaben schon verschoben hat was
tatsächlich auch geleistet werden wo es
das auch wesentlich mehr kreativität
gefordert es beispielsweise also ich
merke schon dass sowohl unsere
kultusministerien aber auch tatsächlich
die schulleitungen und die lehrerinnen
und lehrer vor ort auch die besonderen
bedürfnisse eingehen also ich denke ein
nicht sitzenbleiben ist nicht nur die
möglichkeit komplett alle noten
abzuschaffen finde ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht so ganz praktisch weil auch die
schülerinnen und schüler ungefähr wissen
wollen wo sie auch stehen momentan frau
außer jetzt zu ihnen zurück verzeihung
also vielleicht nochmal einmal ich habe
nicht gesagt dass es für die
abschlussklassen keine noten geben soll
und zu der realität von der freisen man
gerade sprach die realität ist in den
familien wo eltern helfen können und wo
die dem unterrichtsstoff gewachsen sind
wo die zeit haben oder das irgendwie mit
ihrem home office vereinbaren können
sind die schüler und schülerinnen gut
betreut und dann wird mathe erklärt und
dann wird das arbeitsblatt ausgedruckt
und wieder eingescannt und dann kriegt
dieser schüler eine gute note aber in
wievielen familien kommt gerade gar
nichts an und es liegt nicht an den
lehrer und lehrerinnen sondern es nicht
einfach ganz an der überforderung dass
man es gerade nicht leisten kann und ich
frage mich warum wir in dieser pandemie
wo wir so viele themen und wo die
jugendlichen und die kinder so unter
druck sind diesen zusätzlichen druck
erzeugen wollen wo das einfach was ist
was wir uns system irgendwann mal
ausgedacht haben dass es am ende jedes
schuljahrs eine note braucht in diesem
jahr ist alles anders also dass er ein
vorschlag und ein zweiter den ich hier
ganz oft beobachtet habe bei familien
aber auch bei uns zu hause ist warum tun
wir die schüler und schülerinnen nicht
in lerngruppen digital was im moment
passiert ist man letztlich eben das
besagte arbeitsblatt runter oder hat
meine videokonferenz- und dann ruft man
20 mal am tag mami und papi weil man es
nicht versteht statt dass man sagt wir
tun die kinder in vier fünfergruppen
kollaboratives lernen sowieso gut und
die stellen sich die fragen die helfen
sich gegenseitig die erarbeiten das
gemeinsam die geben ein arbeitsblatt zu
fünft ab und nicht jeder 1 das würde so
viel druck von den eltern nehmen und es
würde auch ein bisschen wieder diese
soziale interaktion zwischen den kindern
fördern also was ich nur sage ist wir
haben die situation wie sie jetzt gerade
ist und jetzt als kultusminister sich
mal hinzustellen und zu sagen liebe
eltern auch nehmen lehrer und
lehrerinnen werden höchste wertschätzung
für was er gerade macht und wir helfen
euch jetzt mal mit pragmatischen lösung
erhöht die wirtschaft die kriegt das
problemlos hin die ganze kommunikation
zu digitalisieren warum ist das dann
offenbar so schwer möglich an schulen
kann die wirtschaft vielleicht helfen ja
wir brauchen solide pragmatisch
das fehlt uns ein wenig an ein baden
württemberg angekommen von pforzheim
nicht ohne grund haben wir ja in der
bürgerpartei jetzt gegründet und wenn
ich sehe welche voraussetzungen ihr in
den schulen haben und gleichzeitig sind
wir eine wirtschaftsmacht und wir waren
eine wirtschafts war dann habe ich mich
wirklich wohl bedenken dass unsere
kinder diesem wettbewerb noch gewinnen
können und hier keine noten zu geben und
kein sitzen zu lassen ich werde mal vor
mal so sagen da hat man die realität
irgendwie verloren denn es ist ein
verlorenes schuljahr für die kinder und
die müssen den wettbewerb draußen mitten
in deutschland ist nicht allein auf
diese sondern wir sind stark nicht beim
arosa und kohl kartoffeln haben sondern
weil eingeschneite können wir haben im
moment achten wir nicht mehr auf wir
brauchen bescheinige köpfe er sieht ein
zu veranstaltungen ein sozialstaat nur
aktuell überlegen wie man hoch und haben
und hob erfordert ist heideköpfe wir
brauchen wieder denker und nichtig
denkern und deshalb sage ich klar und
deutlich wir müssen diese hätten wir
müssen die leute aus der wohnung heraus
soll ich glaube mit verlaub viele
politiker wissen gar nicht wie viel
welche situationen denn welcher
aushalten können gar nicht lernt man die
möglichkeit haben dem land ist nicht da
dies ist nicht nennt es einfach mal als
ich würde wirklich alle politiker deren
mann vor seinem einsatz
wir haben über 55 prozent migranten wir
haben sehr sehr viele kinder gehen
nachteilig sind ich habe eine lern
stiftung ich muss jetzt mal aufgerufen
gegen klagt mich an und sagen wie soll
ich lernen was kann ich machen und ich
bitte den politiker mehr vertrauen an
die kommunen ermahnung wir müssen was
tun und ich sagt mit dem laptop mails
grabe kultusminister wenn da irgendwas
gesagt was in betreuung draußen die
voraussetzung ist das ja auch
funktioniert denn was nützt eine
winzigkeit gehabt haben
wir haben so viel schatten aber kein und
wer sondern vorwiegend esel und wir
müssen gucken dass die voraussetzungen
geschaffen ist und irgendwann mein
eindruck ist dass es irgendwie alle
wissen was das schief läuft aber dass
wir den knoten gemeinsam nicht gelöst
bekommen frau bär das betrifft nicht nur
die digitale
sicherung an den schulen das betrifft
auch im moment die digitalisierung der
gesundheitsämter das heute bekannt
geworden dass diese software die so
dringend erforderlich war und die da
jetzt endlich mal installiert werden
sollte um die kontakt nachverfolgung
besser und schneller zu machen
da war das ziel das jetzt 90 prozent der
gesundheitsämter damit ausgestattet sind
da ist die schnelle software da wirklich
läuft erreicht sind heute bis heute 30
prozent und das gesundheitsministerium
sagt es schon blöd aber wir sind halt
nicht dafür zuständig sondern ist ja
wieder die länder ebene wer ist
zuständig wer übernimmt das wer nimmt
denn jetzt verantwortung da in die hand
tragen sie dafür auch verantwortung frau
wer also zunächst mal ist es so dass es
jetzt erstmal auch überhaupt diese
lösung gibt mit sommers dass auch die
gesundheitsämter angeschlossen werden
können
bayern hat jetzt auch seine ganzen
gesundheitsämter verpflichtet und das
würde ich mir von jedem bundesland
wünschen dann kommt da auch wesentlich
mehr druck auf dem kessel aber das ist
natürlich immer die staatlichen stellen
die dann auch zuständig sind müssen
implementieren ich sage es nochmal im
journalismus machen sie alles gut und
schön aber die staatliche ebene die dann
tatsächlich auch dafür zuständig ist
muss das ganze auch aus rollen können
und da haben wir auch im letzten jahr
sehr sehr viel gelernt und ich bin da
trotzdem auch noch mal bei den
pragmatischen lösungen einsatz
vielleicht trotzdem noch zu den schulen
weil man ja auch merkt dass es
funktioniert mit pragmatischen lösungen
wenn ich nur mal sehen
im vergleich die beiden
datenschutzbeauftragten hessen und
berlin der hessische
datenschutzbeauftragte gibt quasi seinen
schulen prokura dass sie
übergangslösungen auch staatliche
lösungen wenn die nicht funktionieren
private lösungen anbieten können in
berlin gibt es ein verbot also das sage
ich ganz deutlich dass sie mir natürlich
diejenigen lieber die dann auch dieses
machen was zu recht eingefordert wird
dann auch tatsächlich realität werden
also auf die sendung zeigt super woran
es in der krise aber ich glaube sie sind
super in der analyse alle miteinander
und ich verstehe dass sie teilweise da
nicht die zuständigkeit haben aber man
kriegt zeit nicht aufgelöst in dem man
dann immer sagt die verantwortung liegt
leider nicht her
möglicherweise ist das auch eine lanze
brechen tatsächlich weil es immer ein
bisschen unterrichtet ist vielleicht
können sie dabei den richtigen fragen
die auch mal ein sagen was unsere
landrätinnen und landräte und die
oberbürgermeister habe ganz oft eher
leisten
ganz oft eingeladen
nein an einer ganz oft eingeladen den
landrat aus dem kreis heinsberg im
landkreis landkreis passau aber schon
bei uns da ganz viele landräte waren
schon bei uns doch dass es funktioniert
die haben jetzt neben dem zentren
aufgebaut bundesweit die auflaufen die
auch funktionieren also insofern hat man
natürlich auch von den ebenen das ist ja
der ganz große vorteil dass man dann
tatsächlich in der kleinsten einheit die
sachen dann auch schneller an die
bürgerinnen und bürger land bekommen
kann ja super frau wir wollen noch
einmal nach der verantwortlichkeit auch
suchen was die november hilfen
beispielsweise angeht viele sind im
moment vor allem den gastronomen
einzelhändler hoteliers die einen noch
längeren locker und jetzt erwarten die
sind am ende auch weil sie bisher ganz
wenig von dem geld gesehen haben diese
beiden haben wir getroffen
ein großes modekaufhaus ohne einen
einzigen kunden
[Musik]
ein skihotel mitten in der hochsaison
ohne einen einzigen gast der lock down
und seine knallharten folgen
bild trifft diese beiden verzweifelten
chefs fabian engelhorn er führt in
mannheim das modegeschäft dass ein
urgroßvater vor 130 jahren gegründet hat
zum ersten mal nun macht sein geschäft
kein geschäft die rolltreppen seit
monaten still gelegt natürlich gab es
schlimme zeiten in der deutschen
vergangenheit aber es gab noch nie einen
tag wo nicht irgend etwas hier passiert
ist und wenn es dann im zweiten
weltkrieg oder nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg die aufbau situation
tauschgeschäfte war aber dass der handel
einen tag zu hatte das gab es noch nie
nun also kämpft sein traditionsgeschäft
mit 1300 mitarbeitern ums überleben ja
wir wurden in dem ersten lockdown und
auch jetzt noch dauern geschlossen
wir stehen auch hinter diesen massnahmen
zum wohl und zum schutz von uns allen
aber wir verlangen auch dafür eine faire
und objektive entschädigung weil er von
den großen versprochenen november hilfen
fast noch nichts gesehen hat fordert er
vom finanzminister ihre bazooka ist
geladen aber sie haben sie eben nicht
abgeschossen
es liegt nicht an uns oder unseren
steuern beratern das bis jetzt erst
knapp acht prozent des volumens was sie
und ihre kollegen zur verfügung gestellt
haben
abgerufen bzw bewilligt worden ist
genauso frustriert ist er jens weißflog
1 skisprung-olympiasieger
vierschanzentournee gewinner seit mehr
als 20 jahren führt er dieses hotel im
sächsischen oberwiesenthal mit 23
mitarbeitern
salzburg
trotz dieses willkommens hier kommt seit
monaten keiner ganz alleine schiebt
weißflog den schnee vor seinem hotel
hält die leeren zimmer in schuss mit
gästen rechnet er noch lange nicht
noch ist auch mal in offizieller aussage
unseres ministerpräsidenten michael
kretschmer wir hatten wir wahrscheinlich
nicht vor ostern eröffnen
dh es dann konkret dass wir innerhalb
eines jahres über ein halbes jahr
geschlossen worden frust hat sich bei
ihm breit gemacht denn eigentlich wollte
er groß investieren zwei millionen euro
nun sitzt weiß flug auf den
zinszahlungen und laufenden kosten er
muss pünktlich zahlen
die versprochenen november hilfen aber
kommen nicht pünktlich wir müssen auch
unseren verpflichtungen nachkommen auch
bei uns buchen institutionen bei uns
buch das finanzamt bei uns bucht die
bank pünktlich ab und es wäre schön
gewesen wenn die versprechungen aus dem
oktober schnell hilfe zu leisten für die
unternehmen die jetzt zeitig in den
lockdown gehen und das worden mit der
gastronomie 23 berufsstände dass diese
hilfen schneller ausgezahlt werden
erscheint sie buchen bei ihm pünktlicher
abzahlen aber zu spät
naja ich sage mal der
wirtschaftsminister hat eine ziemlich
leistungsfähige plattform entwickelt die
mit unglaublich vielen mitarbeitern
mitarbeitern programmiert wird um die
anträge zu bearbeiten
ich habe mir das extra foto sendung noch
mal angeguckt von den november helfen
den abschlägen sind weit über 90%
unterdessen ab ausgezahlt bei denen
dezember hilfen ist das auch so was die
abschläge betrifft und seit anfang
januar seit wenigen tagen werden auch
die gesamtbeträge ausgezahlt da ist
immer noch mal die landesverwaltung
dazwischen die machen das aber sehr gut
das muss man ausdrücklich dazu sagen und
die weisen dann diese auszahlung an so
dass man damit rechnen kann dass das
geld das hier für den november beantragt
wurde dann nicht nur als abschlag so
nach als voller höhe gezahlt wird und
das gleiche gilt dann etwas zeitversetzt
für den dezember
aber das bedeutet ja ist ja genau der
fall nach der 3 1 8% bisher gesehen und
naja
ich sage ausdrücklich das sind diese
abschläge mit einer bestimmten
höchstsumme festgelegt worden
und das was wir machen ist ja eine sehr
gute sehr wichtige vertrauensentzug wir
haben zugelassen und richtigerweise will
ich ausdrücklich sagen dass durch ein
antrag den man beim
wirtschaftsministerium stellen kann der
plattform ohne dass ein mensch prüft
geld ausgezahlt werden es sind auch
schon weit über also es geht auch in dem
milliarden was praktisch ohne prüfung
ausgezahlt wird wir rechnen damit dass
wir allein für november und dezember was
diese hilfen betrifft am ende ein betrag
der weit über zehn milliarden euro nicht
ausgezahlt haben werden und zwar auch in
lola frauen verzeihen sie wenn ich
unterbreche vertrauen ist ja genau der
punkt wenn man es november hilfen nennt
und es kommt im januar oder ist im
januar noch nicht gekommen zumindest
nicht in voller höhe schafft es nicht
gerade das vertrauen das ist ist so
allerdings muss man sich vorstellen was
passiert wenn so viele anträge auf
einmal gestellt werden auf diese art und
weise
und ich habe das schon mal ein anderer
stelle gesagt weil ich finde da kann man
jetzt nicht so mit finger zeigen
arbeiten ich muss den kollegen altmaier
dafür kritik in schutz nehmen wird nicht
unglaublich viel geld investiert um die
plattform zu programmieren und um eine
solche automatische entscheidung möglich
zu machen also sie sind zusammen schuld
sie sind zusammen verantwortlich dafür
und löse das problem auch das ja mal
eine gedankenreise liegt das ist auch
was alle dass alle ja von uns erwarten
können und das kann ich auch nicht ab
wenn man sich gewissermaßen dann so
verhält und sagt ich bin ja nur für
diesen teil zuständig nein sie wollen
das gemeinsam hinkriegen es sind diese
summen jetzt unterwegs die ich eben
gesagt habe und es wird jetzt auch noch
für die zukunft das habe ich vorher an
unserer sendung und unserem gespräch
dargestellt noch umfassendere
unterstützung geben als bisher geplant
ein letzter knoten der noch nicht
gelöstes ist das thema impfen und die
beschaffung die bestellung vom impfstoff
frau poster oder haben sie den gefühl
das gefühl oder den eindruck dass das
jetzt mittlerweile besser läuft
naja die zahlen nehmen ja leicht zu
aber wir kommen gleich auf das zitat
lasse ich nicht stören darüber sprechen
wir auch schon auch noch leisten und
zwar über die beschaffung sprechen genau
den gegner also die zahl nimmt sich ja
leicht zu aber das ist ja das mittel der
wahl um über all die themen die wir
gerade reden mit einem schlag zu lösen
und insofern würde ich mir einfach als
bürgerin wünschen dass am dienstag ganz
viel darüber gesprochen wird wie
beschleunigen wir den den impfstoff oder
das impfen wie starten wir all
diejenigen mit ffp zwei masken aus die
in interaktion treten müssen also
supermarkt bahn wenn ich da lese dass
herrscher jetzt prüft ob man in der bahn
eine fsb zwei maske trägt warum ist wir
das prüfen wenn wir wissen dass das zu
weniger ansteckung führt dann führen wir
das war jetzt einfach ein
das beschränkt und nur minimalen maße da
man ja eh schon im maske trägt und wie
können wir schnell testen besonders da
wo menschenleben gefährdet sind also in
dem pflegeheim in den krankenhäusern
damit nicht noch mehr menschen sterben
so und diese drei maßnahmen die würden
aus meiner sicht und dienstag perfekt
füllen ohne dass wir darüber reden was
können wir jetzt noch alles zu machen
was kann man noch verschärfen und wie
können wir den bürger und bürgerinnen
noch mehr versagt auf ausgesagt löst
erst mal schön dass im problem sie haben
ja da ein ganz ganz langen fragenkatalog
ausgearbeitet beziehungsweise
ausarbeiten lassen und den an herrn
sparen geben lassen hatte den eigentlich
komplett beantwortet mittlerweile einige
antworten können nur zusammen mit der
europäischen kommission gegeben werden
die sind also dann für diese zeit
angekündigt das wird nach und nach der
fall sein dann halt nicht ganz
zuversichtlich und gleichzeitig haben
wir uns aber auch
darum gekümmert dass sich die lage
bessert ich glaube durch die debatte
auch die die wir hier führen ist es
jetzt so dass viele zusätzliche
bestellung ausgelöst worden sind und da
hat der gesundheitsminister das jetzt im
griff alle am freitag habe er noch mal
eine richtig schlechte nachricht nämlich
kann die zugesagten irgendwo sind
erstmal nicht liefern das ist eine
bedrückende nachricht in der zeit wo wir
jetzt alle nicht genug impfstoff haben
allerdings geht es darum das ist uns
gesagt worden ich gebe das hierzu wieder
uns als bundesregierung meine ich schon
gemeinsam dass das dazu dient die
produktion in dem britischen werk
auszuweiten und dann müssen wir ein paar
tage genutzt werden da etwas zu ändern
gleichzeitig ist es so dass jetzt neue
zusätzliche produktionskapazitäten dazu
kommen in marburg und auch an anderen
stellen so dass wir also mit vielen
zusätzlichen impfstoffes wird es noch
dauern und dauern leider haben gewirkt
bin dafür dass wir uns die sache gar
nicht so leicht machen werden wir jetzt
zu recht
also fragen ist genug bestellt worden
ich habe die frage ja selber gestellt
und sehen dass jetzt mehr gemacht wird
und mehr bestellt wird und alles das
passiert ist gibt es aber ja doch
mittlerweile eine ganze reihe von
zusagen was im stoffe betrifft und da
wirklich nur alle sich darauf
vorzubereiten im zweiten quartal wird es
um millionen impfungen pro woche gehen
und da muss ganz deutschland darauf
vorbereitet sein denn wenn wir den genug
impfstoff haben dann sollte sich die das
grab umdrehen dass wir sagen jetzt
kriegen wir nicht verimpft das muss dann
rechnen sie mit dem nächsten ärger
deswegen saniert da muss man ja ärger
muss weg da darf gar nicht auftreten ist
das fragen sich auch eine verantwortung
oder sagen sie es gerade in richtung von
ihrem kleinwagen und eine phase ich
empfinde das immer als gemeinsame
verantwortung wir haben als
bundesregierung die landesregierung die
landräte die bürgermeistern
bürgermeister alle haben eine große
verantwortung dafür dass wir das in
gemeinsamer anstrengung und die augen
letzter punkt wir haben das zitat gerade
schon eine sehr gesagt kommt von ihrem
spd kollegen und bundesaußenminister
heiko maas wie er sagt heute nämlich
ganz interessant geimpfte sollten wieder
ihre grundrechte ausüben dürfen so sagt
das heute in der bild am sonntag bisher
war linie der bundesregierung eine
andere sind sie team sparen der genau
das anders sieht oder sind sie team
heiko maas der jetzt sagt erste sollten
ihre grundrechte wieder vollständig
ausüben
also ich bin team deutschland wenn ich
das so sagen darf es geht nicht um das
wohl unseres landes und da muss man auch
eine solche frage diskutieren dann
persönlich ich persönlich glaube dass
das jetzt nicht ansteht und habe das
gefühl dass es auch eine debatte sein
kann
die gar nicht so praktisch ist wie sie
jetzt vielleicht bei dem einen oder
anderen geführt wird
denn in dem augenblick in dem viele
geimpft sind und diese frage plötzlich
interessant wird sind ja vielleicht dann
so viele geimpft werden worden dass die
ganzen beschränkungen ein großer teil
davon uns weniger als jetzt nach und
nach ins wasser was sollten wir uns
solche fragen dann zu wenden wenn das
soweit ist warum ich persönlich bin sehr
zurückhaltend ich habe mich auch immer
obwohl es ja viele leute gibt die
anderer meinung sind aber das muss man
aushalten ich habe mich zum beispiel
immer auch verhalten dass man sagt der
krankenversicherungsschutz den jemand
hat er muss allen zu stehen da kann ich
nicht sagen du machst aber so ein sport
dann kannst du fährst in skiurlaub da
kannst du dich jetzt nicht beschweren
dass du jetzt
man muss ja etwas zahlen wenn du zum
arzt geht sollte ein beinbruch hass und
deshalb glaube ich müssen wir schon ein
gefühl von solidarität haben auch wie
wir mit so etwas umgehen schlussrunde
dazu vbr
das was herr maas sagte impfte sollten
wieder ihre grundrechte ausüben dürfen
würde zum beispiel auch ganz konkret
restaurantbesuch bedeuten wenn man halt
geimpft es wenn sie gut finden sich
schlecht ich finde es ganz wichtig dass
wir erst mal schauen ob wenn man geimpft
ist man auch überträger sein kann ja
oder nein
es spielt natürlich eine ganz ganz große
rolle dann bin ich vielleicht geschützt
aber kann trotzdem noch das virus weiter
geben
punkt zwei ist natürlich so lange wie
eine situation haben dass gar nicht alle
geimpft sind die auch gerne geimpft
werden wollen würden
ich bin ich kann man so eine diskussion
auch nicht führen zumindest jetzt noch
der falsche zeitpunkt da wir müssen
jetzt erstmal schauen dass wir alle geld
bekommen jetzt sind wir schon so weit
dass wir fast alle alten und pflegeheime
durch haben wir eine situation haben
dass wir hoffentlich ende februar dann
auch alle über 80 jährigen spätestens
geimpft haben werden und so geht es dann
sukzessive weiter und deswegen ist es
jetzt momentan wo sehr viele bürgerinnen
und bürger gerne einmal eine impfung
hätte ich auch bei uns geht's also
hoffentlich geht es der mehrheit so dass
man sagt ich wäre es auch schon gerne
gehen und dann die zweite diskussion die
olaf scholz an stunden ist dann
natürlich die richtige dass wir dann
auch viele positive beispiele brauchen
um alle die vielleicht noch etwas
unsicher sehen soll ich mich impfen
lassen möchte ich mich wirklich impfen
lassen dann auch dazu zu bekommen sich
impfen zu lassen da es dann sicherlich
auch ganz viel damit zu tun dass
diejenigen die dann auch vorbilder sind
in der gesellschaft dass die dann auch
sich vielleicht öffentlichkeitswirksam
impfen lassen um dann die letzten
skeptiker jetzt keine
verschwörungstheoretiker sind aber die
vielleicht etwas vorsichtig sind auch
dazu zu bekommen sich dann die impfung
geben zu lassen walter zeitpunkt für die
diskussion sagt frau bär sagt leute da
auch herr scholz an ich finde man es
gibt keinen falschen zeitpunkt für
diskussionen es gibt nur vielleicht den
falschen zeitpunkt für sie das zu
entscheiden frau eisenmann wie würden
sie es im moment entscheiden
also das ist genauso wie sie auch man
muss diskutieren das ist teil von
demokratischen prozessen
gerade in so einer schwierigen phase
muss man um die besten vorgehensweisen
streiten weil ich ihre einschaltung ich
glaube aber tatsächlich das lässt die
erste aufgabe ist wirklich viele impfen
zu können wir ein großes problem ältere
menschen den impftermin wollen über
hotlines diese zu vermitteln dass viel
verzweiflung geht unsicherheit auch
nicht die digitale kompetenz die sich
manja wünschen möglich ist aber einfach
nicht als direkte schritt und ich glaube
man muss vorsichtig sein eine
impfpflicht durch die hintertür
einzuführen würde ich für falsch halten
und deshalb erste frau aus da ganz kurz
grundrechte vollständig zurück wenn man
gewinnt ist das heißt dass die menschen
nur gegeneinander auf dann geht der eine
in den laden rein und dann sagt der
andere du bist eigentlich jünger als ich
wieso bist du schon geimpft und dann
fangen an engagierte bürger in der bahn
nach ins pässen zu fragen wenn jemand
keine maske auf hat und das ist
irgendwie nicht der start den wir
brauchen die nächsten monate dass man
mit dem finger aufeinander zeigt und
sagt wie so dass du das schon und ich
noch nicht aber wir müssen jetzt
gemeinsam durch aber erhöht das würde
doch ganz enormen im spirit bedeuten
würden jetzt herr scholz hier sagen
würde also ihr könnt ab jetzt wieder
oder bald wieder fast alles machen wer
geimpft sei das würde enormen ins bild
vermitteln meinen sie nicht ich bin der
meinung dass können gar nicht politiker
entscheiden bei einem rechtsstaat in
einer der aggressoren mir sagen ich
lasse leute rein geimpft sind und somit
kein schaden bei anderen anrichten bin
ich überzeugt dass viele richter sagen
ja das sachsenweit gegen des menschen
ist unantastbar artikel eins ist und
nicht ab dem 10
und deshalb bin ich so der auffassung
dass darüber ließe sich ein bisschen
zurücknehmen müssen wenn die grundrechte
einzuschränken bedarf schon eine große
hürden
diese hörbiger dann nicht mehr da sein
die leute ins team und sich anderen
damit keinen schaden anrichten nach
nicht der meinung wir werden viele
richter anders entscheiden wollen es ja
gar nicht entscheiden haben wir der
runde gesehen die halten die diskussion
im moment für früh wir danken allen für
die diskussion die ein bisschen länger
gedauert hat als wir geplant haben danke
all das sie so lange für uns wach
geblieben sind hierbei bild und beenden
möchte ich die sendung einmal noch mit
dem vizekanzler
denn wir haben heute ja historische
bilder aus moskau bekommen alexej
nawalny der wir haben ihn genannt den
mutigsten mann der welt zurück gereist
sind seine heimat und dort am flughafen
aber ja von den kameras vieler
journalisten begleitet direkt am
flughafen festgenommen wurde und im
moment an einem
bekannten ort ist was fällt ihnen zu
diesem jahr beeindruckenden traurigen
bilder aus moskau ein herr scholz
zunächst merten arbeiten die ist
wirklich ein mutiger mann
denn er wusste ja mit vielen
ankündigungen dass er dann nicht
freundlich empfangen wird von der
staatsmacht
und ich glaube das ist auch klar und
wichtig ist zu sagen das ist
rechtswidrig
diesem mann ist unrecht geschehen es ist
ein mordanschlag auf ihn ausgeübt worden
und er müsste vom staat geschützt und
nicht verhaftet werden können sie
irgendwas aktuell jetzt ist ja in
russland können sie irgendwas aktuell
für ihn tun
wir können mit unserem haltung und
meinung klar sein wir haben im schutz in
deutschland geboten das war unsere
möglichkeit und dafür gesorgt dass er
gesundet von diesem schrecklichen barren
und lebensbedrohlichen anschlag
und jetzt wird es darauf ankommen dass
wir da beharrlich unsere haltung auch
weiter vertreten und klar machen dass
wir das so sehen übrigens sie sagt mein
gefühl dass das ziemlich jede
deutschland so sieht also die sagen wir
wollen die müsste vom staat geschützt
werden das glaube ich relativ klar nach
der geschichte dass genau das nicht
passiert also deswegen noch mal die
frage was können sie tun müsste sich
möglicherweise die europäische union da
einschalten mit noch mehr kraft ich bin
sicher dass alle beteiligten zu dieser
frau auf diese frage reagieren werden
wir das bisher auch geschehen ist und
natürlich gibt es auch wir haben viele
die sich für die demokratie und freiheit
in russland einsetzen die werden auch
dafür sorgen dass dass sie uns nicht
einfach im dunkeln verschwindet und das
muss licht in die sache und das ist der
beitrag den weg leisten können mit
unseren möglichkeiten unter anderem aber
ehrlicherweise muss man sagen ab jetzt
das liegt nicht nur an ihrer hand sie
können nicht beschützen
er hat sich in den machtbereich des
russischen staates begeben sein risiko
kennen und trotzdem müssen wir sagen es
steht ihm zu sich als freier mann und
russland zu bewegen und sich um
politische mandate zu bewerben und das
darf nicht dazu führen dass die
staatsgewalt und alles gegen ihn
unternimmt danke olaf scholz danke an
alle in der runde die heute so emsig mit
diskutiert haben danke ansieht dass sie
zugeschaut haben und wir sehen uns nach
den wichtigen entscheidungen dieser
woche in dieser sendung in diesem
politiker bei bild am sonntag abend
wieder um viertel vor zehn bis dahin
danke
[Musik]